it's nice to see you again inspector  we're going to build a spot I thought  maybe you could help  he was stationed on a supply train that  got robbed last night  only one type of critch I know that  could fly him up there  you think a pigs did this who else  can't help you  we are a nation under attack from within  it is my duty to send a message to any  twitch considerings Edition  a gift from the chancellor to the Fine  people of the road  execute  it's falling apart and we can't just sit  at home and do nothing  what have you got in mind  [Music]  take a closer look at what you're doing  to us  I thought if we were peaceful they'd  show us Mercy  but now we know the truth if they shoot  at US Nail our heads against a wall they  will pay for it in their own blood  go after them they'll come for all of us  the whole row will burn  [Music]  they should be afraid of us  [Applause]  [Music]  no one can stand in the way of what is  coming they all human  foreign